my wedding design for a PDA is the
portable and I essentially it's a table
that was made additional approach and
the table surfaces meet with epoxy resin
which is essentially plastic the
inspiration behind this piece are wars
are the quail epistle group this from
Norfolk tourism in such a way whereby
they steam layer upon layers thus are
creating the colorful multi-layer effect
of a steamed cake this project the idea
came upon me that maybe I could do it
likewise the cast plastic in this case
epoxy raised in the same way the most
difficult about this was really the
whole project initially started as an
aim to in a design designer make a table
I went to consult several industry
experts on casting resin and often they
told me that I see that was impossible I
was too difficult to achieve the finish
that one because this has never been
done before this is the first sample
that we made in our first tryouts it
shows how when he posted raising is a
plot on the open surface it will run but
in this case I was experimenting with
different sorts offer Phyllis to adjust
the viscosity and the consistency of the
resin when is in the pouring state so
that when appalled it kind of like
mushrooms are like a macaroon and stays
the shape because of the high surface
tension has created through the fillers
that I was able to layer these little
puddles and to make the table as you can
see for me my design philosophy is
always something that I tend to see
designers more of a medium than a means
to an end winning the president designer
was a surprise for me the fact that it
was a success was already a joy to me
and I'm really humble bided the
president designer what is an important
award Singapore sets a benchmark of
design at the highest level my advice to
emerging designers is ready to learn
about design or two then bend the rules
and lastly you know if you can to break
the rules
you